[Music]
farting welcome this session is the war
record high calculation we have gained
thirty one point four trillion digits my
name is Emma I'm a developer advocate
for Google Cloud and and I'm Alex II
high-performance competing specialists
just curious how many of you out here
know me either personally or online or
who have used white printer in the past
have you used Y cruncher in the past
okay so okay cool cool nobody
we have dory it's a it's a online
service to ask questions if there's a
link from your app so if you open the
session you have a link to Dory and feel
free to put your question output we also
have a mic for live questions we're
gonna take questions later
so we announce this achievement on pi
day this year we have a twenty one point
four trillion digits on Google cloud so
today's talk is about so we're gonna
take a brief look at the history of Pi
and then we're gonna explain how did we
do this and then we'll explain the
technical details of why cruncher the
program we use itself and later we have
a section for our future work so let's
take a look at the history of Pi and
computers so as donor Ignace the author
of the other computer programs said in
his book human progress in Cal creation
has traditionally been measured by the
number of this man digital pi so
humanity as collectively have tried to
calculate as many digits of pi as
possible since 2000 BC and since it sees
the fourteen hundreds we found it
to cut the pie and since then we were
able to calculate pi a separate from the
geographical geometric features and then
in 1949
we used the very first electronic
computer ENIAC to kite eight pi so they
did 2037 digits and ever since now we
use pi at the benchmark for
supercomputers and the last record was
in 2009 and the yellow on it's hard to
see but the record of by béla was the
very first record on a desktop computer
and then the previous record in 2060 was
peter Trobe and alex and they did 22
trillion digits and we did thought he
want tree on digit this year and this is
the first world record on down on cloud
so there are two forms of pi computation
and we want to forensic visually to
first of all it is to compute all the
digits from the start to end so you want
to compute a chilling the years you want
to compute from 3.1415 all the way to
the ones willing to get this is the most
commonly talked about by computation it
is very memory intensive because of the
ahmadi is involved the current world
record is the one that we just said we
want more trillion digits by me and Emma
the other form of computation is to
compute a small number of binary digits
of pi at a specific offset a the this
type is it uses a negligible amount of
memory usage so it's embarrassingly
parallel in the current record is 10 to
the 17th the hexadecimal digit by
Daisuke Takahashi last year this method
is also used to verify the computation
of the first type challenges the
computing PI so computing matrix of Pi
is extremely memory intensive at the
current record frontier we're 31
trillion digits
it requires hundreds of terabytes of
memory to to compete communication
memory access is the bottleneck
it's so bad that computational power
doesn't actually matter anymore
this latest competition that we had 431
trillion digits actually had an 8 to 1
bottleneck on disk i/o the sustained CPU
usage averaged about 12.2% in other
words the complete the computation like
the amount of work to do computationally
is actually negligible compared to the
my disk i/o so why is computing so many
digits so many times if this is actually
quite complicated but oversimplify
things of all day there's a very low
complication to communication ratio um
the runtime complexity a computational
work is o + log n queue but the
communication is actually Oh n log n
square so there's only a log and ratio
by comparison a lot of dense linear
algebra stuff tend to be linear or even
higher and this is exacerbated by the
memory wall so for the past few decades
um is some of you will whatever you know
the performance gap between the CPU and
memory has been increasing exponentially
and it doesn't just apply to memory also
applies to disk and so in this age um
the only thing that matters is the disk
i/o efficiency so the graph of the
picture on the right is actually a run
in the middle of a sample computation um
the bottom the bottom row here is the
disk i/o usage and you can see that it's
completely saturated at about 3/8 a
second in the top is the CPU usage and
it's spiky it's not sustained because
the whole time it is waiting on the disk
i/o so challenges PC computations pcs
are not very powerful it's just one
machine they have a little mount of
memory so you can't really go much more
than like maybe a couple hundred gigs of
memory and so the picture on the top is
actually my PC that I built in 2014 not
that impressive
so because pcs aren't very powerful um
you need to run them for a very long
time and for computations as large you
actually need to use disk because you
can't fit a hundred terabytes of data on
to a PC
um and so the use of the usage of disk
to do computation is called out-of-court
computing I won't get to that later
supercomputers they have a different set
of problems first of all they're
expensive and they have limited access
access tends to be limited to those who
are in academia or those who work
closely with them in the industry Oh
secondly they're more difficult to
program for you have it's not just one
machine there are many machines I have
to deal with communication parallels
limit and there's a lot of different
topologies for supercomputers
nevertheless supercomputers can actually
still run but as a as of the state there
are no publicly available some program
is actually doing and now we're going to
talk about our overview of the overview
of our architecture and the corporation
so as we said this is the first record
down on cloud we calculate the
temperature in digits pi pi times
attempt times power by 13 and we spend
120 one digits as we said we use a
program users what would be called why
cruncher and we is one main compute node
with nice six PCBs with 1.4 tables
around and I think one of the most
interesting statistics is we were nine
petabytes of reel and eight petabytes of
did we wrote eight petabytes of data and
the overall cost is approximately
$200,000 but we have various techniques
that we could have done to save cost and
also this is the first time when we
record were broken on the cloud service
any cloud service and on SSD so all the
past records on PCs use hard drives and
we also use the avx-512 the
intelligibility esteemed extensions
which could which properly saved the
power consumption during co-creation
why would you
want to use a cloud suddenly it's easier
to run the program you can run
off-the-shelf program without modifying
it and it takes minutes to start a
cluster so we run 25 machines and it
takes about a minute or two to start
these 25 machines it's much faster than
going to a hardware store and building
your own computer and also it's more
reliable cloud tend to have fewer
hardware failures compared to your
desktop computers and we have mechanisms
to reduce failures and we line migrate
virtual machines for one from one node
to another in the case of maintenance
etc and even when there is a hardware
failure you what you need to do is only
restart your instance so you have
shorter in mean time to recover and
operations are easier to when you take
backups with your physical machine you
need to copy your entire hard drives but
on cloud just need to take snapshots and
everything can be done remotely
I moved from Tokyo to Cielo during the
project but I didn't have to move the
physical machines and the calculation
was running in one of the dead centers
boo goo goo as we said we have 25
machines but one of the machines is the
biggest machines which run wipe rancher
it has the latest on then the latest
skylake processor with 96 BCPs 1.40
robots around iran Windows Server
because why cruncher is mo optimized for
Windows and it hurts auditor buses SSD
to store the final results and we needed
117 terabytes of disk 170 so 70
terabytes of disk so we added 24
additional knows providing a storage and
bandwidth and each of them has 60 SV
CPUs with 60 gigabytes of RAM and they
are just Linux servers
and I Scotty togas and we mounted the
sois notes from the Windows server when
we were deciding the main compute node
on there couple factors first having
more cores or faster CPUs means more
computational power so the calculation
done would be done in less time and more
memory means less i/o because we can
buffer and bring more data up at once
and we had two instance instance types
with the biggest amount memory one is in
one mega means 96 with 96 CPUs this is T
socket skylax system with 1.4 terabytes
of RAM and the other choice is n1 ultra
members 160 with 160 V CPUs this is a
full circuit Broadway system with almost
four terabytes of RAM we decided to go
with the N 1 megohm in 96 because it's
supposed a B X 512 as illicit it's an
extension of the Intel Architecture and
and it's faster than the previous
generations and also having fewer
sockets means there are fewer new models
that means there will be fewer less
memory access overhead so actually any 1
megohm in 96 could be as fast or maybe
faster than the 160 BCP machine so we
picked up the first choice and immunity
store on hundreds of terabytes of data
we needed to have network capacity
storage using ice ecology so you can
attach up to 64 terabytes of persistent
disks to one compute engine but we
needed more so we had to attach CDs
these disks apart from a craft cloud in
fracture so this is done on the
operating system level so it's not
subject to the limit and instead of
using hard drives their standard
persistent disks we decided to go with
the SSD
because nobody has tried using SSDs to
calculate pi like what war
record-breaking PI and to connect these
disks we used why crunches own rate
system one way is the first reason is
it's optimized for wipe rancher so it's
more efficient and the second reason is
when you take it you when you take
snapshots you don't have to worry about
the sting synchronization between disks
if you set up a single huge file system
you might have to worry about the
metadata of the disk but if you when you
have different disks you don't have to
worry about it so I decided to use the Y
crunchers random layer and I run
benchmark with 20 24 32 nodes and 24
knows seemingly perform the best so I
pick 24 it achieved 26 Giga bps weight
and 16 VPS right so it's almost the
network limit there are additional
tactics we we use to keep the cross up
and running and the first one is the ice
pudgy drives during live migrations and
of course back rubs and snapshots are
important for these kind of long-running
computations and we also set a
monitoring the first point is live
migrations so Google Cloud especially
compute engine line migrates virtual
machines for from one node to another in
the case of Reglan infrastructure
maintenance of Applegate's network and
park maintenance in the bed centers host
OS and the bus upgrades so these when we
perform these kind of maintenance is we
migrate the virtual machines so that we
can perform this maintenance work
without affecting the guest operating
system and this consists these gray
areas it's hard to see but it's more
than half of the total row migrations
and small portion is the possible
Hardwicke
such as memory this CPU network if you
if we see all these signs of Holloway
failures we also migrated partial
machines to another machine and it
easily finishes in tens of microseconds
to finish - might move one note the
other but not for why cruncher or this
kind of memory in this workloads so this
is the our diagram of line migrations so
first of all first I we start to copy
the memory from one node to the new new
node and then if when we copy like most
of the data we stop the VM and move a
state from the old VM to the new VM and
the reset execution and if there is any
outstanding dirty pages on the odd node
we continue to copy the data and finish
the right migration so the meter is the
block out peer so we completely sawed VM
but the other two parts are gray out
abroad so we keep moving the VMS but we
see working in the another food but the
problem is memory bandwidth is almost
always faster than network bandwidth so
it's a typical tree socket machine you
have probably on 200 gigabytes per
second on memory bandwidth that means
1600 Giga bps but usually the user
network is around 100 gigabits PS and
why contract could rewrite one point 4
terabytes of RAM in less than 15 seconds
you will never catch up copying the data
and and this is this diagram is profile
for memory profiling results were
cruncher and the average bound wheels on
a one socket machine is more than 50
gigabytes per second so it's still
faster than the network so my during the
live migration we stopped the BM and
copy the essential memory regions and
then we start the VM
so it during the brownout Pro process
the VMS keep running but it it just gets
slower and in this case it took about 15
minutes to finish through our migrations
and for the record the typical live
variation is much faster and there in
fact 97% of live migration don't have
the post copy process at all so they
copy everything before they stop a p.m.
or they restart the VM and ninety-nine
point two five percentile of the
duration is 660 milliseconds so it's
much it's usually much faster so this is
how why cruncher is an extreme workload
on cloud and the default type I study
time at the body was too short so during
the slow burn of phase these drives
actually timed out and the connection
was disconnected so I had to increase
the time of body to 900 seconds so that
they these drives won't get dismounted
and backup was also an important point
so when you run Y cruncher it always are
automatically sales checkpoints during
hydration and you can restart the check
we start from these checkpoints when for
example the Holloway of program crashes
but these checkpoints are over reaching
a synchronous tree each time so if used
to stop if you crash during
checkpointing or if you take backups
during intake pointings these snapshots
know these checkpoints are not not
necessarily complete so backups needs to
be taken outside these windows and we
use persistent persistent disk snapshots
to store the checkpoint files and in
order to make the process more
consistent I run scripts to make the
process make the ultimate process
automated and manually run the script
once
twice a week when the white cruncher
program was not running for
checkpointing and backup so only useful
if you haven't registered from the
backup that means you don't have a
backup so i actually crush the machines
and stop the program i made sure i was
able to restore from one where snapshots
so i practiced some disaster scenarios
before actually running the main program
main competition and using persistently
snapshots is actually best full backups
it automatically compresses and stores
incremental backups so it's really fast
when you have less change and fewer
changes for example these are the copies
of the same this side each each of the
disk discs is ten terabytes but one
generation is 1.8 terabytes and the the
next generation is only 2.6 or to make
up 2 megabytes also and it's really fast
it's it sometimes takes less than 10
minutes to copy them terabytes of 200
240 terabytes of disks and it's also
cost-effective even if you have 170
terabytes of data it it only costs four
hundred forty five hundred dollars a
month it's much cheaper than the regular
persistent disks and as from wintering
we set up both Sakura bank data dogma
time because we won't kind of want it to
explore and on this is the actual
dashboard during location so we put some
CPU numbers and these numbers and we
said a lot would go to go off when
individual host goes down and the
average CPU usage of an hour of the
compute node was less than 1%
so that means why cruncher somehow
crushed or the there was something wrong
with the operating system and this these
a lot worked very well and I shared this
dashboard with Alex so we we we
independence independently independently
checklist progress of the calculation so
after the calculation in hindsight this
might seem like a simple task a running
program that you downloaded from
internet for four months but before we
big yes before we began we didn't know
that we could calculate this mini digit
number of digits or with network drives
or own cloud and we didn't know that a
single VM can run for four months and
the heavy load nobody
maybe maybe somebody did but we didn't
know and nobody did try the white
cruncher with network drives for these
large calculations and network drives
are also able to handle these kind of
heavy iOS
so these are some learnings we we have
and now we know it's possible to run
these kind of heavy workloads on cloud
and that's that's great you can solve
your own programs with the cloud not
necessarily pi so now I'm going to talk
about white criteria so we throw in that
name around a gazillion times already
white culture is the it's the program
that we use the computers thing um which
I wrote over the past too long so what
is it it's a desktop application for
Windows and Linux are running primarily
on x86 and X and they and x64 it can
compute mathematical constants to
extremely high precision billions
trillions of digits
what can we compute pretty much all the
major constants pi e colon ratio Euler's
constant and the latest version can
actually do custom formulas so if you
want to compute the square root of pi
sure have at it if you hate pie and
you're a towel person yeah it will do it
primary uses um it's mostly for
benchmarking PCs I'm a big part of the
the computer building and overclocking
community and so I kind of wrote this
program both for myself and everyone
else in the community and so I I have a
whole bunch of machines at home
overclocked and yeah I use my own
software to test my old hardware both so
yeah for benchmarking and for stress
testing which is the other half of
enthusiasts PC building and lastly of
course is to set records for all the
constants today it's set the PI record
six times
plus it holds the records for all pretty
much all the other major constants I'm
so the screenshot is just as simple like
it's hard to see a snapshot of the
program computing 10 billion digits of
pi on my computer so history of white
culture this thing goes back way too far
I'm not stretch animated blender so 2006
April APCs high school class of my
senior year the project was to write a
four function calculator in Java and um
after that thing finished I kept working
on it was fine and so I over the summer
I added new features like square roots
trig functions constants and then I
started optimizing it for performance so
I added a J and I see back in at some
point I started to realize that some of
the features were actually faster than
commercially available products like
Mathematica one of which was the order
master roading constant and so that year
my freshman year of college I I computed
160 million digits of other Mascheroni
constant for what I thought was a world
record at the time turns out it wasn't
someone had to billing digits but they
had announced it yet and so yeah that
was kind of a letdown but anyway a
school took over I didn't do anything
doesn't seven um
because I have schoolwork to do but then
2008 while I was in one of my really
boring lecture classes I'm a terrible
student by the way I wasn't paying
attention and so I kind of I came across
a new a new algorithm for performing
large modification I didn't really
believe it at first but after some
analysis I realized it actually solved a
long-standing problem that prevented the
thing algorithms from benefiting
significantly from parallelism and so I
saw them believe so when n implemented
this thing and I finally realized oh my
god this thing is actually for real so
for that reason alone I implement ireia
mented everything from scratch since I'm
natively in C and I built a really
really big computer this time to try
again for this record and so next year
sure enough my roommate and I we
competed fourteen point nine billion
digits of the Euler Mastroeni constant
this time it was a world record and
that's when I officially named it why
cruncher why being the Gama symbol for
the automatic running constant to the
right since then like during later that
year of my room and I basically swept
the constants list so basically because
of the multiplication algorithm what we
had was essentially a cheat code that no
one else had in a multiplayer online
game so it's an unfair advantage that I
exploited to the maximum possible
fullest extent being somewhat of a game
I used to peak so 2010 was was when I
started to add out of core support so I
mentioned the word out of core earlier
out of core is the ability to use this
storage to do computation when when you
don't have no memory and so after that
was added um I went ahead and computed
500 billions of e that was a new world
record and then later that year I joined
up with sugar condo of Japan and he with
his much bigger computers basically
swept the remaining constants square
root 2 colon ratio and E as well as PI
itself the big one the one that the only
one that really matters since then um I
mean I've since left school I don't have
as much time anymore so it's mostly been
incremental improvements minor
improvements like optimizations
enhancements it's been rewritten once
the program has been used to set five
more PI Rho PI R Eckerd's and as well as
most of the other constants and during
this time I started refocusing the
program towards the overclocking
community adding new features for stress
testing and benchmarking and validation
and so you can so people actually use
the program for competitive
benchmarking competitive overclocking
what is it like today
why furniture is half a million lines of
C++ no longer heavily developed because
I have a job now and there's some I'm
doing some research with cluster and
supercomputing but realistically
speaking that probably isn't going to
happen given that I don't have as much
time as I used to and so to the right is
the computer that I built with my
roommate in 2008 to just set the first
set of Records so features a white
cruncher first of all I use this mostly
state-of-the-art algorithms I'm not
actually going to go to talk about in
detail of any of these because you can
easily google them up because it would
take me weeks to literally go into all
the stuff but I use this fast Fourier
transform for large multiplication
binary splitting for series summation
and Newton's method for for division in
square root the program is parallelized
and it is Numa aware so it will be able
to utilize really big machines with
hundreds of course on the Micropolis
district rent it it can use all the late
all the latest instruction set
architecture extensions like SSE AVX
avx-512 on the memory side it has tons
of cache and memory optimizations to
tackle the memory wall and then to get
over the memory limit as I mentioned
earlier it has out of core computation
to use this door should overcome the
memory limit and lastly um which is
actually more important than it than it
sounds its fault tolerance more one is
the ability for the application to save
its state so you can resume it later in
the event of an interruption that's
called checkpointing and the other one
is software error detection to detect
errors that that happened during the
computation that are not detected by the
hardware so implementation detail in my
country so as I said this thing I've
been working on this thing on and off
for for 10 years now it's half a million
lines of code I'm not you know I cannot
go into every portion of it I'll be here
for a year so I'm going to focus on
three parts that are
looks like we have ventures to the
audience that's here namely the article
computation how do I utilize this for
computation how do i do checkpointing
and how do i do fault tolerance so I
offer computation motivation not enough
memory no PC today has a hundred and
sixty terabytes of RAM and when they do
in a couple of decades your browser's
gonna end up using all of it anyway so
that is a really yeah yeah that's not
gonna help conceptually use disk as
memory each C++ object is a file on disk
and use Ram as the cache for disk and so
all the data actually logically lives on
disk and if you want to do any
computation on I get to manually bring
it into memory do your work and then
write it back in other words this is a
form of manual paging
so what are the difficulties of this
this is very slow
I just seek is tens of milliseconds a
cache miss to memory is on the order of
a hundred nanoseconds so there's quite a
few orders of magnitude there and so you
can't just take a gorilla written for
memory and just put on the disk it's not
gonna you'll be here the rest of your
life secondly because of all the
explicit data transfers there's a cinema
significant amount of coding complexity
likewise there are separate
implementations for end memory and out
of course so much of the code is
actually duplicated twice it's written
twice and lastly um the last thing you
need with all this complexity is
something to get in the way
like the operating system and so you
have to fight it I'll get into that okay
so this picture here is sure your condos
on comparable [ __ ] use a set the record
back in 2012 yeah lots of hard drives
lots of red cables it's this is awesome
this is amazing for a computer he was
he's likely so fighting the operating
system 2009 was when I started doing
when I started implementing the out of
court on Windows you have to defeat they
always disk caching if you allocate a
large file on disk and then you start
accessing it it the way that white
rancher does Windows is going to page
it's gonna try so hard to catch that I
will page itself out of memory and so
nothing
the whole system does freezes your mouse
won't move your keyboard won't respond
it's just hangs there and so the only
way to save it
well not save it is to hit the reset
button and so after fighting this for a
long time the only way to actually fix
solvus is to tell the windows to get out
of the way and so in other words do the
buffering yourself which means I have to
deal with all the sector sector
alignment the read-modify-write Duhamel
man of my old buffers again adding even
more complexity to the program secondly
is security zeroing so if you allocate a
one terabyte file on disk then you're
right to the end of it what happens in
Windows is that it will actually zero
the entire file from starting to finish
so what should be an O an essentially
free operation - one one byte at the end
of the file ends up taking hours because
you're watching the heart I just grind
through the entire file to get to the
end
um this is needless to say not
acceptable from a performance standpoint
why does he always do it because the
contents of the disk are going to
contain the lead of stuff from previous
files and so if you have like a password
there that's been deleted soft deleted
and then you allocate a large file on it
without zeroing it you can now access
that data and so it's actually a
security vulnerability and so the only
way to bypass that zeroing is to get is
to obtain privileged elevation but it
took me a long time to figure out that I
had to do that 2010 was when I pour the
program to Linux and so I had to fight a
different set of a different set of OS
issues in Linux
um the failure cases were less egregious
on Windows at least I wouldn't hang your
system and and freeze it and require
hard reset but overall I was never able
to achieve the level of performance and
controls I could in Windows for example
on Windows I bypassed the disk i/o cache
by using a special flag and it always
respects it if it doesn't it fails it oh
it fails the API call and so I know on
Linux
um the equivalent flag is called a
direct sometimes the kernel will respect
it sometimes it doesn't it might pass
but it doesn't really respect it
and so in the end the program doesn't
know in the end you get hit with the
performance sometimes a large
performance hit so the next topic is
application checkpointing the ability to
save and resume applications date
motivations ok this computation took one
hundred twenty-one days um there is no
way this thing is staying up for 121
days things are gonna crash there might
be bugs in the program power might roll
out if you forget to disable Windows
updates that will screw you over to I
know and so um there is a very high
probability that it's not gonna run to
run all the way through them on the run
and so the difficulties of saving estate
is that one there's a very complex
program state like I said it's half a
million lines of C++ there is a long
execution stack there are recursive
algorithms all over the place hundreds
of functions there's no built-in
mechanism the C++ to do check pointing
for you and lastly there was a huge data
set this communication required 160
terabytes of data and if checkpointing
means copying that data somewhere else
and your checkpoints are five minutes
apart you're not doing anything you're
not getting any work done you're just
copying data the whole time and so um
the first thing like the most important
thing is to actually get rid of the
overhead checkpointing we're just to
integrate it with the out-of-court
computation so as I mentioned before us
in an out of core computation C++
objects are files on the disk and so
checkpointing is simply renaming the
file and then write protecting it so
which is that's essentially zero
overhead and then secondly it is to
actually checkpoint only when the disuse
is just relatively low so while the
program so while the competition needed
160 terabytes of disk most of the time
it's actually less than 50 but this is
those occasional spikes that actually
hit those limits on the actually cause
it to be so high and so it beats if I
strategically checkpoint when it's low
then we don't need as much backup
storage to store the checkpoints
okay checkpointing a c++ how do I do it
it's a total hack I don't claim this is
the best way but it's way it's a it
works and it if it ain't broken don't
fix it
so I explicitly manage maintain a copy
of the execution stack when I enter the
function when I enter a function that is
running in out of Core mode I call into
the the check pointing framework and it
and and it reads it tells it that okay
I'm entering a new function and a new
stack frame and so therefore I have the
state separately that I can use to
serialize on checkpoints for program
flow itself i abused follow-through
switch statements especially when the
program is running normally it runs
through the it runs through the switch
statements as of the cases weren't there
and then when you're loading from a
check point
the moment you start the function you
call into the framework it tells you
what to jump to and boom I'm here and so
it skips everything at each case I have
to declare all the live variables in
that stack frame which is unfortunately
it's very manual it's very error-prone
so I spent a lot of time manually
testing all this stuff but once I had
this sort of programming idiom set it
was very easy to extend it to pretty
much the entire program so the example
here is an act is the actual code from
the implementation of a slightly
modified of this presentation some of
the comments have been changed to - to
explain the checkpointing as opposed to
algorithm itself fault tolerance
okay long-running computation it doesn't
mention things are gonna break check
pointing allows you to pause resume and
backup but it doesn't catch silent
errors so silent hardware errors they
are a thing
why furniture has been used to set the
pie record six times four of them have
had Hardware errors two of them two of
those actually had silent hardware
errors
and so silent horror errors doesn't it
doesn't blue screen or computer it
doesn't it doesn't crash it doesn't quit
the program it's just it's it just
corrupt your data and so it's all wrong
and so if that happens when you'll get
to the end of computation and the digit
will be wrong and so you've wasted
everything and it can happen for a
number of reasons CPU memory disk
controller and so the only solution here
is actually to use this is to build
error detection into the software and
once you once you catch some errors
retry and then resume from a checkpoint
so here's an example of a typical divide
and conquer algorithm if you detect a
fault on this on this node does redo the
whole block no big deal so how do I do
software error detection it's most on a
case-by-case basis there's generally two
types of these sanity checks and
deterministic checks sanity checks a low
overhead they don't catch all errors
deterministic checks they tend to be
more expensive but they will catch all
errors with high probability examples um
if I want to check to see if any data is
corrupted I can hash it before and after
the usage period and if the hash the
same thing it probably hasn't been
corrupted that's a deterministic check
that's expensive you use two different
formulas to calculate the same constant
if the formulas are completely
independent and they share are no work
that will catch all if they don't match
and that means something is wrong so
that will actually catch all errors both
hardware and software and then we get to
the more domain specific things like
Newton's method convergence Newton's
method if any of you for those of you
who are familiar with it involves
iterating an algorithm until it
converges
well it doesn't convert you know
something's wrong and so um yeah modular
residuals if you're doing integer
arithmetic addition subtraction
multiplication you know you can actually
keep a to keep a modulus of the large
numbers over a prime number and
propagate that along with these large
numbers because modular arithmetic is
closed under those three operations so
you can do a whole bunch of large
operations and then check the
Jools at the end this is um this has
this is a deterministic and it catches
and it's relatively inexpensive the last
one is through the most obscure of them
it's hard for me to explain but it's
also the most important one in the
program it is to check the coefficient
sizes in a fast Fourier transform so
long story short fast Fourier transforms
are used for large multiplication we use
it for it's used for polynomial
multiplication based on the size of the
inputs and we can you can prove how
large the outputs will be for each
coefficient and anything is better than
that you know it's wrong this one has
pretty much 100% test coverage of a
large multiplication and which is pretty
much probably 90% of the computation and
apply computation so what's the scope
error detection catches 90% of the
hardware errors from empirical testing
which is good but not something that you
could rely on but on the flip side of
that it also catches software bugs
because the error detection it it
doesn't distinguish between software
error box so what we have here is self
testing code which allows me to be lazy
so if I'm writing something that I know
is going to have a hundred percent
coverage by a higher love error
detection check I don't even bother
testing it write it and then let the let
the code higher-up deal with it later
and so this is an example of the program
failing on in error check so future work
as far as why cruncher um the program is
in a steady state now I don't really
have any major future plans for it it's
just a hobby that I work on every now
and then I'll continue to make
incremental improvements and as I
mentioned earlier there's some ongoing
research on scalability like how do I
make this thing scale better on Numa
cluster computing supercomputing but
these are like there's very little
effort going today and for cloud itself
we will continue to have better hardware
and we will be able to target models we
just announced instance with 12
terabytes of RAM that's huge and for
other types of workloads we can we we
prove that cloud is capable of doing
mathematical large-scale computations so
we plan to find and solve more compute
intensive use cases
[Music]